for the longest time the two biggest
retailers in the world were amazon and
walmart alibaba was briefly ahead of
walmart over the past few years but ever
since their stock got crushed they have
fallen back underneath walmart i don't
think any of these companies surprise
any of us though as walmart amazon and
alibaba sell everything underneath the
sun but ironically none of these
retailers are currently the second
largest retailer in the world that title
actually goes to the home depot
not only does home depot have a higher
market cap than walmart but they're
actually pulling in more profit over the
past 12 months the home depot profited
21.38 billion dollars while walmart
profited 18.43 billion dollars
yet the home depot isn't hyped up by the
media its founders aren't criticized to
death and they aren't constantly accused
of being a monopoly to most people home
depot is just a friendly neighborhood
hardware store and that's pretty much it
so how did such an inconspicuous and
relatively niche home improvement
retailer become the world's largest
physical retailer
taking a look back home depot is
actually a relatively young retailer
being founded in 1978 by four men named
vernon marcus arthur blank ron brill and
pat farah at the time the booming 60s
had come to a close and the inflation
crisis was nearing an end homeowners who
had bought their homes during the
economic boom of the 1960s were in a
really good position as their homes had
skyrocketed a nominal value due to
rampant inflation so these guys had
plenty of equity in their homes and as
long as their jobs somewhat kept up with
inflation their monthly mortgage
payments had become significantly more
affordable so a lot of homeowners were
in a position where they could afford to
fix up their houses or even upgrade
their houses but unfortunately the
process of improving your home was super
tedious especially if you were trying to
do it by yourself
homeowners often had to shop around
multiple hardware stores to buy simple
tools and if you needed something unique
you were basically screwed home depot's
founders had of course picked up on
their shortfall and they felt that they
could address the issue so bernard and
arthur contacted investment banker named
ken lancome to secure some startup
capital
they would use this money to lease some
retail space from jcpenney and open the
first two stores in atlanta georgia
called atlanta's do-it-yourself
warehouse but despite the quick start
home depot didn't enjoy quick success
when this store opened its doors the
founders decided to do a promotional
campaign where they would hand out 700
to random people and invite them to come
spend it at the store but they weren't
even able to hand out all the money by
the end of the first day as they
couldn't convince enough people to try
the store
things weren't much better on the
supplier side either most vendors didn't
want to deal with a new store without a
proven business model
in fact things were so bad that the
founders resorted to stocking the stores
with empty boxes and paint cans to make
the store look fuller than it really was
despite the bleak outlook it didn't take
long for home depot to lock in on their
first differentiating factor which was
customer service
from the very beginning home depot
prioritized a great customer service but
it wasn't until a few months into
running the store that customer service
became a differentiating factor bernard
recalls that one day early on a customer
came to a store to return an item but
the customer felt that the employees and
bernard had been so helpful that they
felt bad about returning the item and
asking for their money back so the
customer brought some okra that they had
grown in their garden to give the burner
during the return of course the okra
didn't make it any easier to run the
business but it clearly showcased the
importance of happy customers from then
on the home depot embrace district
policy of the customer is always right
one of the best examples of this was
when a customer tried to return a tire
at home depot you see here one of home
depot's first stores was built inside a
warehouse that was originally a tire
store and one day a customer came to the
store to try returning a tire that they
had bought from the old store and
despite not having saw the tire
themselves home depot accepted the
return the tire was then hung on the
cashier stand to remind employees of
their company's core values aside from
keeping customers happy home depot also
prioritized employee happiness bernard
and arthur knew firsthand how important
this was as they were on the other side
of the coin not too long ago before
starting home depot bernard and arthur
were both working at a hardware company
called handy dan bernard had been
serving as president and arthur had been
serving as cfo but despite their high
ranking positions and good performance
they were both fired by stanford sigolof
who was the ceo of the parent company
sanford was notorious for putting
employees under extreme pressure and
brutally firing dozens of employees at a
time he was even nicknamed ming the
merciless so arthur and bernard were
well aware of how it felt to have a
douchebag boss and they were determined
to avoid a similar path to this day
employee satisfaction is one of the key
advantages home depot has against
walmart home depot currently has an a
minus company culture score while
walmart has a c-minus despite such great
core values though the company still
wasn't doing all that well in the 1970s
home depot ended their first year in
business with only eighty one thousand
seven hundred dollars in sales and that
was from running three stores but it was
just a matter of time until these
investments into their customers and
employees started to pay off
by this point it was clear that simply
offering a great customer experience and
convenience wasn't enough to track large
numbers of customers
retail giants like lowe's were starting
to place a greater emphasis on home
improvement which simply made it even
harder to compete home depot needed
something extra to stick out and they
would hit the jackpot when they started
hiring trades people home depot started
hiring full-time electricians plumbers
carpenters and painters these experts
would stand around their respective
departments and answer specific customer
questions
for example what's the difference
between a breaker and a fuse when are
you supposed to use primer how do you
fix the clogged drain and so on and so
forth home depot encourage customers to
call the store if they had any
additional questions and many stores
even ran instructional workshops this
made home depot the go-to place if you
wanted to ask questions or get advice
and given that most homeowners are noobs
or amateurs at home improvement this
attracted a lot of customers
within the first half of the 1980s home
depot sales exploded from eighty one
thousand seven hundred dollars in 1979
to 256 million dollars in 1984 and now
that home depot had serious sales
suppliers started taking them much more
seriously home depot was able to
negotiate rock bottom prices and they
passed on these rock bottom prices to
their customers so not only were
customers able to get super low prices
but they were able to get knowledgeable
customer support for free shopping at
home depot became a no-brainer for most
customers but it wasn't all that rosy
from the back end hiring this many
experts while maintaining razors and
profit margins was super expensive the
company went public on the nasdaq in
september of 1981 and this helped them
raise 4.093 million dollars but their
debt was much larger than just a couple
million dollars and it was growing
exponentially between 1983 and 1995 the
company's long-term debt skyrocketed
from a manageable 4 million dollars to a
scary 200 million dollars this made
investors extremely nervous and many of
them left in droves by 1986 home depot
stock had sold off 67 percent
nonetheless home depot continued on
their relentless expansion effort
in 1999 home depot would successfully
overtake lows and sales which made them
the largest home improvement chain in
the u.s
but their biggest threat hadn't even
been founded yet and that's of course
amazon there is no doubt that physical
retailers have gotten destroyed over the
past 20 years due to the rise of online
sales but not only has home depot not
been heard by online sales but they've
actually thrived in the online
environment
when it comes to home improvement items
there's often a sense of urgency with
each purchase
maybe you're mounting some cabinets and
ran out of screws or maybe you cut a
piece of wood too small
most people don't want to wait two days
or even one day for amazon prime
shipping their first instinct is to run
to home depot so they can get back to
work as soon as possible and given that
90 of the us lives within 10 miles of a
home depot running to home depot is a
far better option than waiting for an
amazon delivery this sense of urgency
has created a natural advantage for home
depot's physical locations but home
depot has done much more than simply
rely on this advantage home depot has
transformed their stores into a hub for
online shopping for example if you look
up what you need on their website you
won't have to spend any time searching
for the product
not only does your website tell you what
other product is on but it'll tell you
what bay it's on they even have an
option to text you the location of their
products so that you don't have look it
up again in the store
you can also choose store pickups which
makes the entire process even easier
most of the well-performing retailers
like best buy and walmart have adopted
similar models but this has proven
especially effective for home depot and
that's just the buying process when it
comes to home improvement there was a
lot of returning because you either
bought the wrong thing or you bought too
many and i think we'd all agree that
most of us don't want to sit around
shipping stuff back to amazon by this
point home depot had stores customers
and revenue the only thing left to do
was breaking the profit
over the past 10 years home depot has
basically shut down their expansion
effort their global store count has
barely moved over the past decade but
their net margin has gone to the moon
since the 2008 financial crisis home
depot's net margin has boomed from just
three to four percent to a solid ten
percent to put that in perspective
walmart's net margin is currently at
just above one percent to make things
even better home depot's revenue has
also boomed over the past year and a
half from 112 billion dollars to 147
billion dollars it looks like being
stuck at home has resulted in a lot more
demand for home improvement items i'm
sure skyrocketing lumber prices have
just helped the situation even further
all of this growth has pumped home depot
stock to above 400
which comes out to over a 1.3 million
percent lifetime return that's nearly
seven times apple's lifetime stock
returns
at the end of the day while home depot
overtaking walmart may be surprising at
first glance when you take a look at
home depot's fundamentals and compare it
against walmart's it makes perfect sense
not only is home depot cheap and
ubiquitous like walmart but they also
provide a combination of knowledge
expertise and convenience that you just
can't find in any other singular
location
and as long as home depop holds their
excellent service they'll probably just
continue to outperform walmart do you
guys prefer home depot or lowe's comment
that down below also drop a like if
you're glad to see other retailers
challenging walmart's dominance and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest custody ideas and
to consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]